after a rough voyage we've arrived at
the end of the Tracy Arm fjord to search
for glacial ice oh my god gorgeous
beautiful so we're looking for what
sighs there's what we want to look for
something that's very rounded right what
about that one that's it no Gordon I
don't think that one's gonna work that's
like your own private island let's try
this one here to the left the white one
at eleven o'clock ten thousand years in
the making these glaciers produce the
purest ice imaginable perfect for
cocktails so the secret behind this is
screwing these into the big block yes
and then after that we're gonna hook it
up and we're gonna hoist it on board
don't you this is the most fun I don't
nice cube my tablet I hope this is gonna
make it the best cocktail let's just
trust me price you ready yes okay start
screwing we're gonna hook it up to a
d-ring and if it's not all the way in
it's gonna crack the ice you have to
kind of be like over the water you know
so you're on top of it let's just make
sure they're really down deep are you
kidding me Michelle they can't get any
further in there okay look yours is
coming out
mine's coming out yeah you got to get
that in deeper deep yeah you're not all
the way in when we pull that up on the
wench it's gonna crack perfect
[Music]
[Music]
good job amazing so you take the outer
layer off so we put that in the glass
and what do you think for a little Scot
and now we need a little vermouth I feel
like one of the luckiest mixologist
anywhere on the planet look at the
colors good Alf
look at that what an ice cube oh my lord
that's strong I think it's 110 fruit
amazing well done
I have bars but I've never ever touched
an ice cube but that's that perfect and
it just tasted so clean and fresh and
slightly effervescent in a way that it
was almost lightly sort of carbonated
and a great way I think to toast the
beginning of this incredible cook with
an amazing cocktail laced with glassier
ice cubes
[Music]
want to see more for my uncharted
adventures please click here to watch
more clips